hey
hello hey it's the cutest
little comic book show on the internets
hey
welcome ladies and gentlemen to fat man
beyond i'm kevin smith
i am mark bernardin
he needs more sounds look at this
sideshow set this up
comic book show or the internet hey
and it's not i mean it looks expensive
and i'm sure it was but like it's
plastic it's not like ceramic so yeah
you can kiss it and stuff like that it's
got real hair on top gorgeous
anyway little baby assassin look at him
look at him he's eating frog eggs and
[ __ ] look at this [ __ ]
look at that sexy i went to t public
and i picked up some uh nate shirts of
fat man beyond artwork
look at you patronizing the arts look at
what comes with baby yoda
that's weird isn't that funny it's like
the accessory the
little gear shift that he was
um how have you been my friend uh since
the last time we spoke you know
pretty good can you feel a
brand new day can you feel a
brand new day and even though there's
been some weird noises today
yeah from uh the other side
let's just concentrate on what we know
to be real
indeed we are not living in the in the
conspiracy vacuum
of like no no it's it's it is what it is
did you find out i mean we didn't find
out on election day obviously it took a
few days it was saturday morning i was
writing at like 5 30. i woke up at 5 30
in the morning
started writing and then around whenever
they announced it
i was uh i heard somebody like outside
the office like
screaming in the street and i was like
what the [ __ ] and i looked outside
and then i heard three different people
like yeah yeah
and instantly i was like oh my god and i
looked at
i went to cnn by hulu and [ __ ] there
it was man
yeah i i was just waking up saturday
morning and uh
and like my wife and you know to a
lesser degree and myself have been just
glued to the tv
just kind of like doom-scrolling our way
through
you know the the three or four days
since election day
and i had gotten to a point where i was
like i can't watch anymore because
they're not saying anything new it's
just more of the same
and so like saturday morning i woke up
and like resolved not to put on msnbc
and then just kind of like flipped over
and it was the moment where the like
and we can now with uh confidence say
that pennsylvania has gone
to former vice president joseph r biden
and then you know i put on with jams and
like ran out of the room it's like it
happened we won
and and it was jubilation apparently the
world round
yeah man there were parties in the
street [ __ ] look like nub
yup nub bebop and yup [ __ ] look like
return to the jedi
on saturday in real life
for sure man it looked like we just uh
we we brought down the independence day
aliens and suddenly there's fireworks
all around the world
it was uh it was pretty exceptional
um but yes so now we live in this
brand new world uh indeed which will
still be weird for the next 73 days
yeah and even after that i'm taking a
screen shot cause i'm gonna put this up
on twitter
you do it do it
um but yeah man and it was a weird week
before then because the anxiety was just
high enough that it was
hard to get too much done you know it
was this this weird distillation of
anxiety over the entire year
of like man it's weird and it's covered
and this is happening and
black lives matter's happening and the
world feels unsettled and and
here we are we push to get to this
moment now we don't know and the
it just yeah it was it was hard to to
make any forward progress on much of
anything
this week but now today it feels like a
yolk has been lifted
um well i don't [ __ ] with the oaks
because i'm vegan
i know something's been lifted hey what
was [ __ ] lifted
i i can't speak uh to your situation but
i
i suspect it's similar i have not seen
my wife happier in four [ __ ] years
volumes to my inability to make her
happy
of course in the last four years but oh
my god she was dancing
laughing like out loud crying
dancing she went through the entire
spectrum of human emotions
and it was pretty impressive to watch
yeah we did there was some dancing and
there was some high kicking a little can
can action
going on um and then you know when
speeches start happening and it's like
oh man kamala harris i bet she's gonna
make me cry
i bet she's gonna make me cry yeah she's
gonna make me cry i'm crying it's just
happening now
and also like it was so nice to hear
those speeches because
it's been a while since you know you
heard somebody
be presidential uh especially not take
credit for anything
like you had the biggest highest vote
tally ever for any presidential
candidate
and he kind of referenced it and then
just moved on and stuff
like every every time he spoke it was we
did a good job
like we our team and
rarely did he use the the i pronoun for
anything
yeah it was pretty damn emotional and
whatnot uh but
uh for us the nerd world
goes on man under the
current administration under the future
administration
um it's the nerd news never stops man
i know i mean it did start it took a
pause like this
there was a conversation we had like
last week where we were like
there's probably no news to do until
like next saturday or something like
that
yeah because there was only one story
worldwide
but it was interesting watching
like how quickly people were like yay
and now back to work and
stories started coming out people felt
like
they didn't have to compete anymore with
cnn
that board that'd be nice for us to have
though
john give one of them big boards open up
the counties see who's watching
break it down what's the chatter from
coruscant well let's go to the big board
pull it up
[Laughter]
pretty damn impressive i know we're
living in the science fiction future man
um but yeah like there was i i did find
some time to watch some stuff
because you know the news was driving me
mad so i needed some distractions
what did you see uh well i watched
episode 2 of the mandalorian
you are ahead of me i have not watched
it yet oddly enough
ah so you did not get my embryonic
assassin joke
oh i got it because the internet like
yes
unless you [ __ ] watch [ __ ] fast you
got no room to complain
that uh shit's been spoiled because you
know i didn't watch it on friday by
saturday morning i was like oh my god we
got a new president and people like baby
you don't eat [ __ ] frog eggs
[Laughter]
so i have that to look forward to um
which you know i'll be honest i haven't
seen it in the context of the episode
but
it sounded pretty [ __ ] harrowing i
mean it's
it's it's the weirdest tonal balance
they're trying to pull where it's like
all right we're going to set this whole
thing up
here's this woman frog lady who's got to
take her eggs to another planet to be
fertilized by her husband
and they're like the last of their race
and so here this is precious cargo these
are the last
you know frog eggs in the galaxy
we have to find a way to protect her and
then and then it becomes a comic runner
where yoda is literally just like taking
out percentages of that entire
like bloodline stop eating the babies
there's only eight left in the universe
are they but with their eggs they're
unfertilized eggs right they're
unfertilized eggs
but still those are not babies mark
let's
i don't want to get political but eating
an egg is not the same as eating a child
but yeah i
see it's it sounded like uh you know i
was like are they trying to villainize
[ __ ] baby yoda
uh i don't yeah they weren't trying to
how do they take the shine off baby yoda
i know have them [ __ ] eat
a dying race
it would be like hey man there's like 10
gallons of gas left in the entire
wasteland
that guy likes drinking gas
who directed this episode was carl
weathers i saw
um was it carl weathers yeah himself i
guess that's amazing
directed some television in the past but
he
asked john favreau can i direct an
episode
so they i guess they revealed it um
pretty damn sweet man nice yeah
and a well-directed episode i mean it's
it is
it is another one of the mandalorian
like
if star wars was a cover band these past
two episodes have been like does anybody
want to hear some dune
does anybody want to hear some aliens
here we go you guys
like it's it's very much we're not even
we're playing the hits we're playing
somebody else's hits
um which is a little weird did they go
on a bug hunt in the recent episode
um they very much do like it's it's like
they're on this planet
and hey baby yoda who seems to really
like eating baby things
um finds a an egg in a in a cocoon
on the ground in this alien chamber and
like
opens it up eats the thing and oh
wouldn't you know there's a whole forest
of these eggs
and they all start opening up and all
these spiders come out and chasing them
back
it's aliens um you know it's well done
for sure like it's all it all kind of
you know holds together and it's
spectacular spectacle but it's like no
dude i've seen this before
um for a new thing give them what they
like just
painting that's what it was it wasn't
carl weathers
so the aunt mr ant-man himself mr down
with love mr
uh uh uh what's the other oh uh um
bring it on bring it on um he's a
wonderful director man
i love the ant-man the first ant-man is
great the second ant-man
is also very good but not quite as
charming as the first one was
um way to [ __ ] on the guy when we're
just talking about like he got to direct
amanda lauren you're like yeah but he
did do ant-man and the wasps
well ant-man and the wasp is no thor the
dark world
so true that's awesome good for peyton
reed all right i have yet to watch that
what am i watching i just
uh that hbo series with nicole kidman
the unbelievable
um not very comics genre but still
totally watchable
finished the stars nexium uh
uh you know degrees um
seduced i think it was called or
something uh and they were able to
accomplish in half the time
what the val did over more episodes than
that
and their portrayal of this guy was far
more harrowing
um in terms of gave more details that
were like what
what i saw the first episode and it's
like listen
let's is raping babies really bad
and it's like nuts they said anything
like that in the vow
man like so you were like what yeah
instead it's like this weird romance
between keith renery and and mark
whatever is in vicente
like hey quitos hey marcos what are you
doing
just walk into the woods baby you want
to come walk with me yes i do
like in two episodes of that meanwhile
over here
over at seduce they're like episode one
though like here's the [ __ ]
or who's gonna blow your mind this guy's
gonna say some [ __ ] that'll [ __ ] blow
your hair back
yeah let me tell you what it smells like
to be branded like oh
[ __ ] fun tell me this indie oxenberg
uh we got on uh on uh twitter man steve
karmininsky said watching
uh that kevin smith on fat man
uh beyond can't sleep so might as well
show some love that's our audience right
i was gonna sleep i can't i'll watch
this
marginally apathetic
[Laughter]
um have you seen any of uh queen's
gambit no and i keep seeing
people on [ __ ] twitter uh talking
about that's the girl
uh who was in uh new mutants right yeah
and and the witch
anya taylor joy um is it so far it's
pretty good i'm three episodes in
and i'm kind of digging it um i'm
predisposed apparently to liking
stories about um chess geniuses who have
difficult childhoods
um searching for bobby fischer is one of
my favorite movies um
gosh they'll ruin your game see the
whole board josh
you have to see the whole board josh um
it's a it is it is less uh life
affirming than that
at least so far because it's about this
this young woman
beth harmon it's based on novel but i
don't think it's based on a true story
but
you know her her family is uh she's an
orphan she ends up in an orphanage
um a side effect of being this orphanage
is they're giving children tranquilizers
to keep them kind of
um emotionally stable and when she takes
these tranquilizers she can hallucinate
she sees chess boards on the ceiling
based on a real story i don't think so
it's based on a novel i think
so when she sees the chess board she see
it like
like a beautiful mind a little bit yeah
um and uh and you know her the custodian
in the basement of the of the orphanage
teaches how to play chess and she's a
prodigy
and then she gets adopted and and it
becomes this like
hurt slowly and maybe even not that
slowly but her building this career as
this world-class chess player
even though nobody expects her to be one
because it's the 50s and she's a woman
um and and also dealing with
what eventually will be sort of a
crippling addiction issue with both
alcohol and
and pills and how genius and madness
very often go hand in hand um and i'm
taking it so far that's not at all what
i thought that thing was about
what did you do better job of selling it
than anybody else did no
afterwards no it's really
she's very good um and you know period
evocation of the 50s
is always kind of fun to look at um and
chess i i have a passing familiarity
with it but i don't know it nearly well
enough to know if this is
well done chess right but you don't have
to
you know like it's one of those things
like less about chess
it's less about chess and more about the
dynamics of chess like there's a scene
in crazy rich asians
which involves mahjong i'm like i don't
know at all how to play this game
but i understand what's happening in the
scene and how what's happening on this
game board is helping to dramatize it
like i get that she thought she was
losing
but she's telling her truth and while
telling her to she gets the winning hand
and she
displays it for the mother like it's all
that thing and so chess operates the
same way
you know like i don't really know how
hockey works but i could watch the movie
miracle and understand what's happening
in it
oh my god and if you watch it you won't
[ __ ] cry during kurt russell's speech
[Laughter]
you don't have to like hockey to love
that speech it's an amazing [ __ ]
speech
yeah like that's the the metaphor of
sport i'm sick it's pretty hard
everyone talking about how good the
russians are
[Music]
um queen's gambit queen's gamut would
recommend
i am uh i've not been a fan of uh and
this is
unrelated but the word queen isn't it i
have not
been a watcher rather i should say of
the crown
now i think i'm actually gonna watch
this will be the first season because
they're doing
charles and diana and margaret thatcher
and they've got
scully playing margaret thatcher so i'm
feeling so bad
yeah and she looks [ __ ] great like
her performance looks amazing
you could already smell she's going to
get all the awards when they start doing
that sort of thing
so watching that i've seen
one episode of the crown and i watched
it only because
um i was i was an emmy voter this year
for the first time
um and you know they they ask you to
watch
every episode that's up for like here's
the five finalists
you know here's what the category is and
they give you links to watch everything
and i'm like you know what
i i know i'm voting for watchmen like
that's goes the hands down that's what's
happening
but i've never seen the crown so let me
see the one that the crown thinks
is the best crown man and uh it was
episode called abrafan
and it was about this mining accident in
this small welsh town
that killed like 300 children
like this giant this mountain of a mine
collapsed
and this mountain of mud and orange [ __ ]
just
rammed into this small town hitting
first
a school and it's all about a
the tragedy of this event and what's
happening in the town but
how the queen her response to it and how
much it's informed by
propriety and social conduct and decorum
and
you know the queen doesn't go to
accident sites because if the crown
shows up the crown is a paralytic effect
like i suddenly stop
everything because i'm there you know
all of these reasons why she can't go
and like you know her brother goes and
her husband goes and just talks about
the
the just the the bone-shattering despair
of this town
and it sort of comes out spoilers by the
end of it that
she she finally does go and she fakes a
tear
to show the people that she cares but
she's like i've never
cried for anybody like i just don't feel
that you know what
i'm what's wrong with me that i can't
even in the shadow of such
such despair and devastation i cannot be
moved to actual
for real tears it becomes this you know
sort of explanation of of her
weird as when it would have to be being
raised a queen and being a queen since
you know 13 years old
the psychological fallout of all of that
and how it's left her somewhat barren
emotionally
that sounds nope that didn't make you
want to watch the rest of that [ __ ]
it kind of did but then i was like
i because every season seems to have
like a different cast and i'm like well
i kind of like
this cast where olivia coleman is
playing queen elizabeth and i don't know
where this is in the run
and i it became one of those there's a
lot of homework here
i'm sure i'm down for the homework but i
was i was still really
going back and watching the previous
season i'm diving right in with this one
man
nice to try and if it if i dig it then
i'll go back and i've got previous
seasons to watch but i'm drawn in more
because i'm like well this is history
that i remember
i was here for this yeah [ __ ] it's
relevant to me so i was alive
i'll eventually be getting into that and
i still have
yet to watch now i i said on twitter uh
the dude from spain made that movie that
superhero movie
um that they they do to ask like if
you know biden wins when you watch the
movie so buy
one so we'll definitely be watching that
movie which
is really good i love that he's looking
like
the one [ __ ] program i think we all
watched over and over was
cnn that was the main [ __ ] program
indeed yes the the the election sweeps
event of 2012.
i mean 2020 2012. wouldn't it be great
if it was 2012.
[ __ ] remember that what a great time oh
we could go places
it was amazing yoga hosers hadn't
happened yet
the mayan calendar were still on our
side
um the uh let me see
uh oh who's this jonodiner says on
twitter this is the first time i've
gotten to watch fat man beyond
live and i'm stoked in trump-like caps
uh question since who knows if oliver
would be back in la
if both of you had to use your creative
brains for advertising which industry
would you want to work for
outside of television film
and comics so if i had to make ads to
sell any product what product would that
be
both of you had to use your creative
brands for advertising which industry
would you want to work for
all right so who would we be selling for
is the question i guess like you know
i i suppose there are advertising you
know
executives who specialize in like this
guy's great with automotive and that
person's awesome for
you know female products and that guy's
great for toys or whatever
breakfast cereal i can [ __ ] sell [ __ ]
ass that's material
i love great breakfast cereal
commercials i would go into the where
they make the breakfast cereal and shoot
that cause i think everyone would be
interested in that
love to come up with cereal pitchmen and
[ __ ] like that cool nice
tricks rabbit get yourself some matthew
mcconaughey voice over for battle creek
like let me tell you the story of how
they built this cereal
yeah yeah this is as american as the
blood
spilled on battle creek michigan i mean
i assume they had some battles in battle
creek
one would think you know maybe minor
skirmishes that's
uh is weird and all that [ __ ] cnn
watching and
john king opening up the counties and
[ __ ] i never saw anything from battle
creek
like what's the bat what's the battle
creek report man is are we gonna get a
serial dump or what
that's on you sir
um should point out
the reason uh that we're zooming this
week it ain't because
coveted last week is because i got back
from chicago
and you know didn't want to necessarily
give people cope but if i had it
clearly i don't have covet but the
reason we're resuming
fat man beyond tonight is because one of
us on the show
is a like a step away from bringing
new life into this world man yeah
somebody's
having a baby it is neither of us
let's bring in the baby maker himself
his is so [ __ ] lethal
created life burned through the covid
steed jc and jen uh are about to have a
baby
uh but i mean i should say jen's about
to have a baby and jc gonna watch
but uh the fine uh owners and
proprietors of that their
scum and villainy cantina um who
who've made life are about to welcome
that life so
rather than you know be like hey jc we
know you got nothing going on can you
come open the bar so we can talk about
what movies are coming out we're making
it easier for
for jc to be home by his lady's side in
case
the baby has different plans and stuff
like that so jc how is it you're
minutes away from you know [ __ ] rest
of your life being owned by somebody
else
it's uh it's pretty awesome it's also
terrifying
uh i think we've got what about 17 more
hours
until the baby comes so
it's interesting also knowing the exact
time that the baby is going to come
typically right you're like well it'll
be somewhere in this week but we know
yeah
and also like labor where you're like it
could be this day but how many hours of
labor is it going to be instead
so you guys know exactly when it is why
is that c-section
c-section uh our baby got comfy and
never flipped
and she's just sitting in there chilling
right side up so i mean [ __ ] smartest
kid in the world she don't want to come
out in 2020
yeah like i'm good she wants to dip a
piggy in these waters before she dives
head first
and uh yeah like i hear pfizer is doing
well
with the vaccine let me know when that's
finished
um well this is awesome man you're about
to be a dad for the first time are you
excited
i'm very excited i'm really nervous uh i
have
i was talking to mark before stream and
i think the only thing that's keeping me
together is knowing that
for three four five thousand years other
people have done this before
me and and we made it so it couldn't be
that hard right
very true yeah like and our parents
were able to smoke and drink through the
entirety of the
pregnancy like would you like one of the
little beers miss
well yes doctor i would like one of
these little beers when the kid came out
they would slap them around so
families have survived this baby having
thing forever man
you two kids have your heads on straight
and whatnot
i think you'll be absolutely uh fine i
think you'll be a great parent man
like think about it like you like all
fun [ __ ] that a kid would be into
i uh yeah i think that's the fear though
is that i'll be the fun
one and then they'll have to be a
disciplinarian somewhere in the
child's life truly yeah i
i i i don't know when i was
when harley was a kid i was not the fun
parent like she
[ __ ] loved jennifer and thought she
hung the moon but when harley got older
and figured out what i did for a living
and [ __ ] i became a fun parent
and uh yeah somebody well jennifer
always said that she's like why do i
have to be the disciplinarian
i'm like because i have very few rules
whatsoever for this kid
stay alive i will find you that's my one
rule
um yeah you're gonna be the one that's
gonna be like let's do this let's do
this
let's go here let's go to the movies
you're gonna be the jason muse parent
here's a bunch of legos it'll also be
like
don't go in my office and you cannot
play with my toys
these are dad's toys that'll go nice
[ __ ] fast that that's the first thing
to go away
remember yeah
exactly man you better buy the cheap
version to give to the kid
i remember i used to have like all the
batman the animated series
uh action figures all the the star wars
lineup figures when they relaunched
uh in the late 90s and stuff um
on the wall tacked to the wall like you
know my [ __ ] apartment looked like
a comic book store that's what my studio
looks like at my house
they're all tacked to the wall yeah
jason's been able to hold on to his uh
muse but yeah that was one of the first
things to go
man when once once the kid as a kid
reached up and pulled um uh
clay face out of the package i was like
you've ruined it
yeah and also welcome to the uh probably
better than average chance
that your kid will not be a nerd yeah um
oh if you like that [ __ ] probably the
kid goes the other way you might have a
little athlete or something yeah a
little sports kid
um but luckily you both have expertise
in grinding numbers and stats
um it'll just be different numbers and
stats
i played sports for a while so
[Laughter]
so there's full access to horses
so my fear is that we are going to have
a child that needs a
horse by her sixth birthday
when somebody gets to be the bad parent
and just says no
that's that is such a first world
problem to happen we might have to get a
horse for our kid
she wants a pony i don't know what to
say i gotta get her a pony
yeah and it's none of this pony [ __ ]
you're talking legit horses man
all the neighbors have horses dad why
can't i have a horse
that's a smart sell yeah she'll know
your buttons
and then i'll be like well i mean more
like a tauntaun
and then i'll be like oh well now you've
really done it well i mean tomtown only
if the horse is constantly on its back
feet
uh but more of a tom's on than a dewback
that's for damn sure
yeah so um all right oh you're standing
by
we'll be able to grab baby updates from
you
goes on like is the baby born yet you
can tell it's more
yeah and i'll reveal i think everybody
in the chat wants to know her name
and if it's star wars related so i will
reveal
next week's show will reveal her name i
think
now we have a reason to do a show then
let's do it like as obnoxiously as
possible
like you know how people do baby
announcements and they [ __ ] burn down
half the forest and [ __ ]
we'll just set fire to hollywood or
something we'll be like
to celebrate the baby's name we've put
scum and villainy on fire
then look at it and the color of the
flames will tell you what
sucks the baby is yeah we'll arrange for
an x-wing flyover
oh that'd be sweet um all right man
uh good luck with uh with baby number
one
all right thank you guys probably gonna
have more than that man you seem like a
multi-kid
jen uh was kind of an only child and i
grew up with brothers and sisters and
she watches me with my brother and
sister and
says uh i think our child needs to have
a brother and sister so i would imagine
that
if this one goes well if tomorrow goes
well there'll be another one in the
future
that just means more sex for you man
well done
at least one more time yes
one more encounter one more day
um all right kids we gather together to
ask the lord's blessing and do a show
here
every week and talk about what's going
on in the world
uh now that the presidential election
is kind of uh knock wood out of the way
we get to enjoy the uh the
the news that truly matters ladies and
gentlemen and mark
has gathered some of that news up for us
tonight we're gonna
disseminate it with our simmons
uh right now cement all over it man
you're gonna put on one of them black
lights you're gonna see it
disseminated all over the joint
yeah oh we're flipping all right mark's
got news
ladies and gentlemen mark what you got i
got some news man
um the the rumor of the week
is that uh there is a new star wars
television program
going into production that is that real
i didn't even hear that is that true
that that is true um there there had
been talk
on uh on one of those investor calls
that every studio has
um where uh where the head of disney
said something to the effect of
we're looking at spinning off the
mandalorian which characters in which
sort of storylines we feel can offer us
you know the the possibility to make
more shows like it
there's already a uh the kenobi show
which is happening but it's not spinning
out of the mandalorian like it's okay so
that's
this new show that they're making is not
the kenobi show yet
it's not the kenobi show um there's
leslie hedland from uh from russian doll
is working on her own separate star wars
show but it seems like
that might be some like parallel
universe in star wars or a part of the
timeline that nobody's ever seen or
heard of before but
you know with characters that we're not
familiar with but that doesn't seem like
it's a spin-off from the mandalorian
side note i um knew
leslie hedlund like a long long time ago
before she
became a powerful like creative force
and before
russian doll and before about last night
remember she wrote the remake to about
last night
i knew her from my days at uh miramax
and uh
weinstein company is so what she at one
point i think was like
harvey's assistant if i remember um
worked in his office the very least and
then one day
like you know i remember too like she
would talk about like i'm
i wrote a show an off-broadway show that
they're
putting up and stuff like that and you
know it's very like oh good for you
follow your dreams [ __ ] making a star
wars show
her dreams all right she's like [ __ ]
that i'ma follow your dreams
it was really awesome to see her ascend
and whatnot
we don't know what the star wars show is
going to be though um no
it all seems there's some confusion i
think in the star wars universe
in that season three of the mandalorian
is absolutely happening whether or not
they're going to start
i mean john favreau has gone on record
saying that he wanted to start shooting
by the end of 2021
i'm sorry 2020 um which is like
you know pretty much will happen
before the inauguration he wants to get
going um but then production weekly
had um what they thought was
uh mandalorian season three something
from lucasfilm under the code name
buccaneer
is gonna start production relatively
soon which has sparked this sort of
again this is why it's a rumor
this idea that perhaps it's not season
three of mandalorian but actually season
one of something new
and the something new seems to be
people are you know the prevailing
theory is that
this might be a boba fett miniseries
[Music]
because we didn't i am at the end of
episode one
did they do a runner with him at the end
of episode two or no um
no no that storyline kind of you know
gets
popped in one kind of vanishes totally
in two
but perhaps you know if you've got
tamora morrison
um you know kind of teed up are we going
to see the
here's what happens post sarlacc pit of
boba fett
entirely possible or maybe like meeting
him in one and then he gets some
parallel story going
side by side of whatever you know what
happens you got it right the first time
don't
do that storyline that that would be
[ __ ] astounding man that would be fun
actually a direct sequel to return to
the jedi
that would be pretty bad do you hear me
[ __ ]
um i mean there's also the possibility
um which is a little bit less exciting i
think to
to either of us of uh of a potential
offshoot being
centered on cara dune which was played
by uh gina carano
um or potentially bokeh tan which katie
sakhoff is reportedly
playing in the live-action version of
the mandalorian
so it's possible that there's different
ideas
but it feels as if the rumor the rumor
seems centered around boba fett
so maybe maybe we're getting a boba fett
mini series
um in the distant future um
nobody's saying it could be an ig-11
mini-series
so far there is no ig-11 talk i guess
not right because tycho ytd's off to and
thor
right now so obviously he can't be
[ __ ] around with mandalorian
true but i mean i suppose he could pipe
in and do some voice work from
new zealand uh he wouldn't have to be
there for some reason i was like they'd
need him
they don't even have the real guy
playing the mandalorian playing man
[Laughter]
um well that's exciting we could have a
new star wars show
we could man you know and it seems like
for the next few years i'm sure ain't
gonna be no star wars movies a lot of
star wars shows
you know it is the gift that it keeps on
giving for them and you know
the audience reaction is strong enough
and it must be doing gangbusters for
disney plus
to the brain we're like yeah let's just
keep making more of these
we figure we figure out the tech
wouldn't it be funny if the disney show
is the frog lady and [ __ ]
with a few eggs that are left i know
it's a very slow build of just
like you know sympathy for lady
vengeance
which is like i'm gonna kill that
[ __ ] baby yoda you slaughtered half
of my children
it's like this kill bill of the star
wars universe
yeah like honestly that that sequence is
like the flip
version of the opening of finding nemo
where it's like look at all these baby
eggs nemo oh you're right they'll all be
great
and then a barracuda comes and eats all
of them except for one
um i don't like your version of finding
nemo i'm gonna
try baby yoda
can you go back to the real version of
finding nemo
uh yeah i it's the version that i played
for the kids so often where you just
start
after the mass murder at the beginning
where she's like oh hey look it's just
the one fish and this
is dad what happened to mom we don't
know that's true that's a way less
[ __ ] bloody hammering version
part of that movie i forgot and his lady
gets killed at the beginning
yeah this lady and like 100 children all
get murdered
um classic classic disney
we can do disney or we could really do
disney
what else we got well
um here's a story do you remember how
um johnny depp was in these fantastic
beasts movies
that were based on the jk rowling uh yes
he played uh
uh not voldemort gringo grindelwald
grindelwald
i still haven't seen any of these movies
fantastic beasts i saw the harry potter
ones but i never saw that fantastic
either in the fantastic beasts movie
yeah he uh he he gets revealed at the
end of the first one
um as having been in disguise colin
farrell
sort of pulls off his mask scooby doo
style he's like here's who i really am
and it's johnny depp playing um
grindelwald
and he's just the full-on big band in
the second movie
and he has now um resigned
his role as grindelwald in the wake
of um this ongoing uh
litigation that he's got happening in
the uk over libel
where the the british press um has been
covering
his sort of feud with his now ex-wife
amber heard um
they called him a wife peter in the
newspaper he sued that newspaper
um to have a for libel to say like
uh if you call me that i can sue you
right uh
the court in england upheld not upheld
but they were like
no it's not libel like everything that
you told us here
indicates that he the paper wasn't wrong
for using that term
correct um and so now rather than
deal with having the you know
marginal star of your ongoing franchise
being labeled at least in the british
press where harry potter and fantastic
beasts are
huge like it's a british franchise
being able to refer to him constantly as
wife beater johnny depp
they've asked him to resign the role and
he has
um apparently he only shot one scene in
the movie before they stopped over the
the covet
sort of shutdown but he's getting paid
for all of it
like he's got a paper yeah i'm sure
they'll ask him to walk away but i'm
sure
like he ain't walking away for free yes
no he had a pair play contract
and even though you asked me to resign
and i did you still owe me the
40 million dollars you were gonna pay me
because i'm johnny depp as the bad guy
and you're moving
that's uh warner bros indeed
um so if a warner brothers is like uh
hey uh my name's paul lives between
y'all and steps away
can't imagine disney is gonna hang in
there
yeah i mean it's it's unclear how much
you know
whether or not he was ever going to be
jack sparrow again um
but yeah who knows what their appetite
is for for going down this road as well
maybe just at this point in his career
family entertainment is not on the table
um at least for the time being uh
yeah i mean well he also had a career of
like you know ninth gate and stuff like
that so
if he's no longer playing disney fair or
kids fair i'm sure there's
always work to be had yeah and you know
time
has a way of sort of diminishing stuff
like this not to say that you know
anybody should excuse somebody who's
engaged in spousal abuse
we talked about a bit about that last
week um but it's also worth remembering
that at one point robert downey jr was
in prison
and you know then sort of rehabilitated
his career became iron man
became a star in children's movies and
did all that stuff and like it's
there is no last chapter apparently in
in hollywood so
um you know while this might be the end
of his
um reign in children's pg pg 13
fair who knows who knows
this uh i've seen
various reports across the internet
about
you know there's a lot of what about ism
and people are like well what about
amber heard and
is she how come she's still allowed to
be in in uh aquaman or whatever
and then i've seen like reports that are
like well her role is gonna be
smaller as if anybody would [ __ ] know
that sort of thing
right um it's uh yeah that's a
that was a costly relationship i mean it
seems to have been for both parties
and absolutely i mean some people just
get together and
yipes and this was the case i never saw
any evidence of that
um whatsoever but i when we were making
yoga hosers they were brand new in the
relationship
yeah so i mean it's it's it's always an
interesting case when a giant studio was
forced to deal with a giant franchise
and make a big change sometimes it's
because of tragedy like when
richard harris passed away and michael
gambon has to step in his dumbledore
you know an audience can absolutely
swing with that i mean james bond was
the the beginning of the
oh yeah that's not going to be seeing
the same guy every time and we've had a
few batman's people and a few
spider-mans
but and in a world where you know the
introduction
of johnny depp as
um was it grindelwald grindelwald
was colin farrell going you know they
could just [ __ ]
do that again and suddenly it's somebody
else and stuff
right you know or just hand wave it all
away just it's a different person just
moving on
or you know just be like look between
this and jk rowling
maybe we just start some new [ __ ]
maybe we do something that just doesn't
have as much attach to it yeah maybe
there's a the stink is is a little high
on these fantastic beasts maybe we leave
them in the pen for a bit
truly um yes next
um we talked about a quiet place back in
the day right and the john krasinski
emily blunt
um yeah and it remained on the um
uh billboard in the valley
right by the freeway entrance right by
the in and out
almost the entire quarantine just
recently went down i think
a couple weeks ago for quiet place too
how it was just like it's coming it was
a
grim reminder of the world being put on
pause
because it was like march 13th it's
coming and that billboard sat
up there all the way to the song we're
going like march
it's coming it was a reminder that like
oh it looks scary in their world of a
quiet place
but you want to talk about real horror
like we're
we're all we're we're fighting monsters
we can't even see [ __ ] save
your movie
it reminded me a bit of like i am legend
you know had all these
scenes in times square where you'd see
movie posters from movies
that like had come and gone that was
still in the future like batman v
superman was a movie poster and i am
legend
um and it's just oh yeah no and it was
for a year that had since passed
and so we were living in this weird
post-apocalyptic crater of entertainment
where it's
no no no no quiet place too it's coming
it's coming
when do you think they run out of all
the [ __ ] they shot before covet man like
i was watching that
undoing on hbo and nobody wearing any
masks nobody talking about the virus and
i'm like
oh this was clearly this was shot before
[ __ ] went to hell
yeah run out of that [ __ ] i mean other
than like mandalorian where they don't
have to deal with the storyline at all
um you know it's got to start showing up
and everything they've already started
doing coveted socially distant shows
that have been canceled already
oh yeah kind of like nobody wants that
level of
like it's about this you know this is us
is featuring you know sort of
covet stuff people who are in mass
people are doing lots of handsomeness
that is set in the present like yes
right but it's also the last right like
it tells a couple it flip-flops it's
like there's the you know 1973 story of
the 1982 story and then the modern
present day story
and so yeah like they got characters who
were for sure social distancing and for
sure
at the very least that's part of the
narrative um
a lot of sitcoms are coming back with
that as well like you know um
superstore you know which just premiered
with america ferrero like a lot of it is
you know the first the season premiere
was the sort of time lapse story
about them coming to grips with the the
kovids like oh
they say we gotta stay six feet apart
but maybe it's 20 feet maybe it's five
feet we're not sure
mass bandanas hand cleaning quarantine i
get all just
the weird accelerated pace of of coming
to go through the new world
but yeah we're running out of the [ __ ]
from the before times
you know everything will be the [ __ ]
from the now times
and it's uh it'll be curious to see
precisely how much of it
gets in stories you know on shows like
chicago med
or grey's anatomy or you know
any number of csgs anatomy for sure
they've got to be able to be like we're
overwhelmed that seattle grace
yeah you'd think you'd have to but uh
but anyway quiet place quiet place two
not coming out until next year uh april
apparently 2021 but now there's a quiet
place
universe which i didn't know there was
before um
jeff nichols who did um loving
and midnight express um is writing and
directing
a movie that's set in the quiet place
universe that may or may not feature
either emily blunt's character or john
krasinski's character
oh my god so they're like walking dead
in this [ __ ]
yeah where they're just like we're gonna
fear the walking dead
the fear of the quiet place
right place a world beyond i mean you
know look
god bless do whatever you want but seems
a little early well premature no
yeah but you know i guess i guess the
thing of it is that these movies the
first movie the first quiet place
they made that movie like 15 million
dollars like it was pretty cheap
um and then made 330 some odd million at
the box office and so
i suppose franchising out a movie that
doesn't have to cost that much
doesn't feel like the worst idea if like
hey let's say we spend 50 million on it
clearly there's an audience for it maybe
they'll come back
and maybe there's enough story in this
world where sound kills you
and there are weird alien monsters and
[ __ ] so
it's happening it's coming in a world
where
you know there are any number of
iterations of
zombies and it's not like we're like
it's
it's been done move on somebody does
zombies people are like
i'm here for it [ __ ] zack snyder's
about to do zombies again
on netflix so it's and you know
walking dead still ain't done so there's
i could see it i could see a world where
like it's a little weird just because
we've only had one quiet place movie and
they're like
it's a whole universe where everyone's
scared of these big monsters and nobody
can say anything and [ __ ]
um you know but god bless like i'll
watch it if
if it works and stuff and and you know
in a world where
there are multiple iterations of zombie
films i guess there could be multiple
iterations of like
you got to be quiet i mean look i
just hope that the star of one of these
[ __ ] is silent bob for heaven's
sakes
been training for this [ __ ] for a
quarter of a century
come on krasinski put me in put me in
coach
i lived my whole life for this that
guy's got to be richard and [ __ ]
creatures at this point man like between
like
[ __ ] now not only do they make a
quiet place too which we've still yet to
see
they're talking about spinning off so he
must get a taste of that
and then he stole that [ __ ] good news
tv show remember that [ __ ] when that
happened for a minute
yep he's got this jack ryan show on on
amazon
he's doing all right he's he's starring
in it but yeah this is a guy who's like
not content to just be put in [ __ ]
yeah he's mad manufacturing and making
[ __ ] good for him
yeah and and you know i wouldn't be as
as uh optimistic about it if it wasn't
that the guy who's doing it is jeff
nichols who's like
a legit filmmaker who's made some really
good stuff and did you say
midnight express midnight special
oh okay you you did say midnight did i
say midnight express
i love midnight look i love midnight
express but i love midnight special that
guy's a really good director he directed
another movie i really liked too
[ __ ] yeah he did uh he did he did take
shelter
yeah and uh yeah with [ __ ] michael uh
what's his favorite michael shannon
seems to be
[ __ ] dope yeah he's a great director
yeah
he'd be good totally for that world i
could see that
yeah so like that that's what like oh no
they got a real filmmaker to do this
like they got somebody who's definitely
got a point of view
and a take on stuff john kozinski is
like [ __ ] you mark bernard the filmmaker
too
no but they could have gotten like the
dude who makes resident evil movies and
it's like
whatever this is fine um but uh but you
know it's uh it's encouraging so yeah
wes anderson i am indeed
the john the peter hyams of the the the
modern day
not to be confused with paul thomas
anderson no
two very different filmmakers very all
right
different
filmmakers
news do we have wither thou knows look
at you with the red cup and [ __ ] it's
like yeah yeah baby look at that
edgar and mark bernardin's ladies and
gentlemen but i'm classy because i got
my pinky my quarters next where we do
playing quarters
colonel puff takes his first drink in
the evening like you got a bunch of
people around a table and [ __ ]
and so the first person is like colonel
puff takes his first drink in the
evening and then you do
something like let's say you were like
and then you took a drink
and then the next person goes colonel
puff
puff takes his second drink of the
evening and they do this [ __ ] and then
they
add something like and then take a drink
so by the time you get to like the tenth
person
it's [ __ ] ridiculously long and you
know you're saying
a colonel puff puff puff puff puff puff
puff puff puff
takes his 10th drink in the evening and
then you have to remember
all that [ __ ] that everybody [ __ ] did
see uh i i uh i just drank too much work
exactly
like if you're going to drink i don't
need like some elaborate ruse to get me
to drink
i'm here for this i also don't
understand why teenagers
like were like let's let's take our time
getting the booze into us i remember
being a teenager and it was all about
like i want to be drunk now
and yet we showed discipline
to some degree by patiently waiting to
drink until it was our turn
in a drinking game so bizarre of all the
things you had to gamify
booze doesn't seem to necessarily be the
one you had to do
like maybe the getting of the booze
perhaps they're like oh that's a
challenge
but we have what we want and now we're
withholding it
it's like [ __ ] sex dice where you're
like
who needs the dice like
sex is fun enough who's trying to make
this [ __ ]
more fun if we could just do this right
we don't have to vote for it
it's gonna feel good we'll both be happy
um all right what do we got next baby
wants to know what else is happening
what else is happening is uh is disney
has moved uh
a couple of fox films out of december
free guy the ryan reynolds kind of video
game uh
meta comedy drama action movie thing
um and uh and death on the nile the
sequel to murder and the one express
both of which were supposed to open in
december
21. both have have punted out and for
now this seems
like wonder woman is the last of the
finest
of the studio films kind of holding on
to december as being
a possible birth which is not going to
last because it's 100 moving into 20 21
because the ways covered pfizer just
announced they got a vaccine that's
90 percent [ __ ] effective which
apparently
those are big numbers when i hear 90 i'm
like well call me when it's a hundred
but they're like look
on [ __ ] malaria drugs we don't get
[ __ ] 100 percent like you don't get
so in a world where we know now that
there's a vaccine coming and they're
saying like it won't get to the rest of
the world until the spring
that means every studio right now is
like
just lining up for the [ __ ] summer
you're gonna start seeing
all these [ __ ] movies landing
like jets
um for summer release at this point
because a lot of people are gonna bank
on the fact
that by spring and summer [ __ ]
vaccines gonna be in the hands of
everybody and so
it's it's gonna be like [ __ ] you know
what was it vj day where people are in
the street and [ __ ] like that
yeah i was talking to some friends about
that the next time we all get to go to
comic-con
and it's gonna be like just i'm gonna
lick people's [ __ ]
faces no normally i'm just like hey
but now i'm gonna be like yeah [ __ ]
because
it's gonna be valhalla this is gonna be
this weird crazy becca now for four days
on the water
it's weird man like now whenever i watch
programs
i'm so like hyper aware of
people's proximity to each other and
stuff
um and like just thinking about like man
like
it's even when with a vaccine
we're still gonna be in a different
world where everyone's now
hyper aware of [ __ ] germs and their
proximity to others
and stuff oh yeah like those those
random handshakes you would do to
strangers when you met them it's
probably a thing of the past no it's
this [ __ ] forever man it's gonna be like
a lot of elbows and whatnot if yeah at
all
yeah it's like i'm a hugger not to me
you're not a hugger
you take that murderous [ __ ]
someplace else
um but yeah like there's there's gonna
be you know the massive pileup of movies
coming out and i think that that the
industry's starting to get bullish and
you think today
with the news of the virus of a vaccine
being brought to market at some point
soon
plus you know biden winning the election
and and you know starting launching a
task force to get this thing under
control
i mean everybody's feeling pretty good
about spring summer fall
but for now like with western europe
spiking with america
spiking the idea of reopening theaters
here is
months away overseas it's not like yeah
wonder woman is moving everything's
moving there's no
there are no movies anymore not this
year
um and yet they're making new ones like
aren't they working on
i saw a picture of uh [ __ ] uh
spider-man
yeah spider-man's in production you know
who knows how long they'll be up and
running before they've got a fairly
take a batman size break while somebody
gets uh
gets treated in quarantine for covid i
mean jurassic world fallen kingdom
um or jurassic world three whatever
they're calling it
just rap production the rock just
wrapped on on red notice for netflix
like yeah they're making stuff but
who knows that jurassic park uh [ __ ]
rap
they said was like you know they did
this little piece somewhere i read where
they were like this is how expensive it
was this is how long it took
what a pain in the dick it all was
thanks to covid
yeah there was something like 40 000
tests they went through um
simply to finish production on that
movie you know and
and some of it seems to have been that
it was hard to put that movie in a
bubble
you know it's hard to just say everybody
who's here is here nobody's leaving and
going anywhere
we're all at summer camp gang and we're
here for the duration
it uh it apparently was not easy to do
on that movie so people were coming and
going and bringing stuff and
yeah if you're kept goldblum
you can't imagine you're like yeah i'll
stick around the whole time even when
i'm not working
you know you want to come in you want to
come out and stuff yeah
but like and that's the that's the the
trade-off right like until
until you can convince everybody to stay
here then you're
you're opening yourself up oh here he is
hey buddy
he was getting lonely oh hey pal any any
news about me
whoa this game well i could pick him up
you don't need to stand i just told him
like the dog
like a baby do you just need a bjorn
yes a yodebjorn
um dc comics had undergone
something of a restructuring mark this
is our this is our sitcom picture
oh child and that's the name of the show
our sitcom is called yo dad nice
can this man from earth be a good father
to a baby alien
who wound up in his lap um do you think
this season the mandalorian they say
what race he is or what species he is
like a name because we don't know what
yodas are and we don't know if it's
plural are there a bunch of yodas or was
yoda the only yoda
is this is this yoda i mean everyone
keeps talking baby yoda but we all know
that you know they're like no no no
he's just called the child are we gonna
find out that the child
was indeed baby owner you know kicked
back through [ __ ] time somehow
or are there planet of these [ __ ] you
know like i i had always thought before
we saw baby yoda
that yoda had been something else and
had withered
to that you know at some point yoda was
like he was originally a real live boy
and then he turned into
and then age plus power just turn him
into like a green raisin
um but uh but no i guess that they are
born small and cute and then get old and
wrinkled
like humans um they're born
i know i know a little thing a little
bit about yodas and the one thing you
can't do
is feed them after midnight
and get them wet yeah and
[ __ ] you know once a year
they're allowed to go out and [ __ ]
kill no that's the perk
i forget the perfect
why don't you badass that oh no um dc
uh had a bit of a restructuring they
fired some folks they laid off some
folks they have none named a new
editor-in-chief and then at
this point it might be news if you were
like hey dc hired somebody
like it seems to be a lot of layoffs um
they well they did hire somebody they
have a new editor-in-chief
maria evans marie marie javins
johnson's james james chavins
eic uh bob harris was the old eic
oh that's right they just let go of them
recently like of him recently they put
in this uh this
twin interim editor-in-chief which is
marie javins who had been working there
as an executive editor for a while
and michelle wells who was running the
ya um and still is first of all i know
the y division at dc and so they
elevated marie
to the top slot and she's been working
for years in this
in this business she was an editor and a
colorist for a long time
at marvel and then she came over to dc
you know a few years back to oversee a
lot of their collected editions
and so now she's got the head job
reporting up to um
let's see fella named robert cherry who
was just put in
robert daniel my bad who was just put in
as like this weird vp of warner brothers
who's you know
overseeing all of dc comics jim lee is
still publisher and
creative director and he reports up to
that guy as well
and uh you know it's a press release so
everybody's very happy for this to be
happening but even anecdotally talking
to a bunch of comics creators they're
all like no she's the real deal and
she's great to work with and great to
work for
um even their jeopardy
um for dc like
it's not one of these like they might
stop making comic books
or no they seem very committed i mean i
think everybody is
committed you know especially when
you're owned by the giant corporations
like you know marvel
is owned by disney and dc is owned by
warner brothers i think they will always
make
comic books in some fashion the the
question is always
how much new ground are they breaking
and how much just copyright maintenance
like there's absolutely a version of
this which is just we have to keep
publishing superman batman and wonder
woman because if we stop then we run
the risk of these copyrights beginning
to lapse so
we just need to we need to be custodial
about this line and make sure that we
keep everything viable
but you know are they going to launch a
new vertigo
that becomes this kind of warehouse and
home for new ip
and creator co-ownership and that sort
of thing
probably not you know and and you know
while there's a place like image while
there are other places out there that
actually give creators full ownership of
their stuff
then then it's hard for a place like dc
or marvel to want to compete
um because they can't offer that they're
not in that business anymore
so yeah i think they're always going to
be you know x-men comics is always going
to be
spider-man comics is always going to be
superman comics but
the the enterprise publishing i don't
think is in there
is in their wheelhouse anymore have you
heard any
rumors about dc losing their continuity
altogether
um i mean they talk about this every
like five or six years right like the
new 52
was a lot of like hey we're starting
over from number ones everybody
everything is fresh you know the
perennial reboot
that uh that comic seems to undergo that
always
you know i don't think it ever quite
does what they expect it to do which is
open the barn door for a raft of new
people who want to buy stuff
right as much as just kind of ultimately
piss off
the the ongoing long-term fandom i was
like i
i was buying this book since batman you
know since detective
183 and it was up to a thousand and now
you restarted it why would you do that
um but there's always going to be the
desire if for no other reason than to
have a new thing to market
to say hey guys no continuity it's all
brand new
start here start fresh the rumor that i
read online is uh more than just like
hey a new iteration of the universe
it's that in the universe it's not going
to be a universe it's not going to be
like
they all know each other they all cross
over into each other's books and stuff
which i'm like why would you get rid of
that like
i i mean i understand like
setting creative challenges for yourself
so you create a new story or something
like that but like
i don't see any positive that comes from
like no no
batman's by himself no other people in
in
this world batman's the only person ever
thought to put on a cape and
fight crime and stuff i mean i guess it
allows you to like
you know uh build to the moment where
you're like and now
finally the batman and the superman are
gonna meet each other
instead why like
yeah i i don't see the allure of that as
a reader
um who's read these before
you know and i don't quite see the
allure of that as a newcomer to it who
was just like oh i've heard about all of
these guys
there's a justice league right so
they're all kind of hanging out together
no no no no no we haven't done that yet
it's like why though you know
i just i mean i get it comics are middle
story and they're always gonna
think about somebody other than me other
than the current reader they want the
elusive
reader who hasn't read a comic book in
their lives and that's where all the
money is or some such [ __ ]
but i remember when you know they
flipped the universe and become the new
52 and i felt like wait
all my stories what happened to them
nothing happened to them they're fine
and i could still enjoy the [ __ ] out of
them and stuff
so this if if they indeed start telling
stories that are completely
wholly disconnected from the other comic
book stories they tell
um it would be an interesting uh
creative choice uh and certainly you
know
not one that that i would be down with
yeah i mean it's at the end of the day
that kind of thing is always driven by
marketing
it's always driven by like we got to
figure out ways to get new people to buy
we got to figure out ways to get butts
in the stores
and how do we do that it's all new well
different but kind of the same but a
little different no it's real though
you know or and also to just drive
people to the back list which is like oh
yeah you want to see that other stuff
that they did that before here's
15 trade paperbacks of batman or swamp
thing or whatever that that give you
exactly what you want
we're giving you a new thing trust us
it's going to be great
and when it isn't we're gonna go back to
the old thing i like no
give me the more old thing all the time
um and that's how you become an old
person kids by being like i like it the
way it was
give me tribute to where i used to have
it please yeah we're
we're on our way to being grumpy old men
we are indeed well
not that far uh we're we're gonna close
out the night uh at least the news
portion of the night
with a couple of farewells um
ken spears the co-creator of the beloved
animated series scooby-doo
and the co-founder ruby spears
productions along with the late joe ruby
passed away on friday at the age of 82
years old
now joe ruby his writing partner who he
met
is a cute story the story of ken spears
he was friends
with uh either hannah or barbara's kid
one of their you know the legendary
animation titans hannah barbera
they had kids obviously probably had sex
definitely had kids
those kids had friends one of those kids
friends was ken
spears so he was just hanging out and he
said i didn't know what
my friend what what his dad did like no
clue
so he got a job at hanna-barbera
early on as a kid like a teenager or
whatever [ __ ]
and then uh you know was working in
editing
sound editing and that's where he meets
uh joe ruby and they kind of
click and so aside from like you know
doing the technical work they start
pitching stories
and one of the stories that they pitched
to hannah and barbara is
there's these kids there's a jock and a
hippie
and a brainiac and a fashionista
although they probably didn't use
fashionista and they got a dog
they drive around in a van and they
solve weird mysteries and stuff
um ken spears and and joe ruby created
scooby-doo which is something that i
didn't know most of my whole life i was
like well hannah barbera did that but
hannah barbera bill hannah and whatever
the other
barbarian oh barbara they eventually you
know
you start hungry and building something
and then you get to a place where
you've built it and other people start
bringing you
ideas and [ __ ] like that but those guys
you know they they're
they're like we did all our creating
back in the day
now we're producers and so one of the
most
famous hanna-barbera properties of all
time
not created by either hannah or barbara
yeah yeah scooby-doo where are you was
there was their big thing they also did
dino mutt
jabber jaw dog wonder for hannah barbera
um you know and then even on their own
once they finally left and formed their
own productions
you get they did an animated superman
they did alvin and the chipmunks
mr t plastic man comedy adventure hour
thunder barbarians and the saturday
super kade
thunder other barbarians it's another
one that i would have liked bet my life
somebody with a gun in my head be like
[ __ ] made thunder the barbarian i'd
be like hannah barbera
[Laughter]
um they uh they enjoyed working together
so much they went off and created
ruby spears so like they worked for
hanna-barbera and then they created
their own
cartoon company which as mark said did a
bunch of [ __ ] including
the alvin and the chipmunks like in the
80s
not you know the classic [ __ ] but like a
bunch of saturday morning
cartoon staples like uh you know
they they created their own shingle so
to speak
and then eventually that got sold to
taft which also bought all the
hanna-barbera characters and have
happened which was then bought by turner
by turner and now owned by warner
brothers so
it's uh you know you think you know
a factoid and then all of a sudden
somebody passes away and you're like who
is this
what what do you mean really hated
[ __ ]
yeah exactly um
there's a guy who fostered our
imaginations and uh
killed a lot of time for us in our
childhood
um and even up through past our
childhood i watched that [ __ ]
alvin and chipmunks cartoon man oh yeah
like i mean
i watched the at least two of those
live-action scooby-doo movies
yeah they just thanked him ken spears i
guess
at the tail end of scoob
they did recently scooby-doo movie which
i watched and i actually
i i liked as well and also had
uh blue falcon and dino mud in which is
lovely
other characters these guys created um
80
something years old 82 82
huge bucket of win what a great legacy
man
could you imagine being able to tell
people like oh you you know scooby-doo
that was me yeah me and a buddy we made
that yeah we made that we thought it'd
be real funny and we were right
they got a lot of mileage out of that
[ __ ] for real
for real um so yes he's passed a guy
responsible for a lot of our good times
in childhood
[ __ ] you know uh think about it if
you've ever been like
i would have gotten away with it too if
it weren't for these meddling kids
gotta put those words into the world
ladies and gentlemen
indeed um and we also the the sort of
the weird
boomerang of this past week was you know
the election and the results
um if you were the kind of person who
found a you know a certain sense of
victory in that
it was wonderful like saturday was
glorious
um and then sunday uh came the news that
alex trebek
has lost his long fight with pancreatic
cancer
and has passed away at the age of 80. um
and and it's you know i i did a bit of a
twitter thread about this and that
i mean jeopardy is a part of everybody's
lives like it had been on at some
point in everybody's household here or
there you might have sat down you might
have peered over a grandparent's
shoulders they watched it you might have
just kind of
swung by it and of course you might have
seen it in a movie
like hey white man can't jump and she
wants to go she knows all the key words
foods that begin with q i know this alex
um
you know but it it actually was this um
kind of american institution that was
built entirely around
the pursuit of knowledge like it was all
about facts and
and you know un uh uh unsuspicious facts
just like these are things that are true
literally at its heart forces you to ask
a question
it rewards the curious and uh
and and alex trebek was the sort of
arbiter of that truth
you know he he never professed to know
everything and he would always admit
that there's a staff of researchers and
writers who would
write all the questions and he was just
the guy who was helping to convey that
information but
he he still wielded that power with a
sense of grace and good humor
and authority and you know it's a show
about the
about excellence about intellectual
excellence which you know
has has been part of america's dna
for a good long while seems to have been
on the wane
as of late the idea that that you know
being smart
is not an asset knowing too much is
something to be ridiculed
um it always stood as this sort of
paragon of achievement
and and knowing some [ __ ] made you
worthwhile
and being smart was a thing to to aspire
to
and i think you know we might not have
ever given jeopardy the credit that it
deserves for being that thing
in american culture um a bit like
trivial pursuit you know
spelling [ __ ] is cool on wheel of
fortune but this was about knowing [ __ ]
and uh and that's not now more than ever
that is a good thing
to make people aspire to always been my
favorite
game show um and the one that like you
know
you can be most impressive while
watching
you know what is turkey and then
you're like [ __ ] like that um
it is uh been an institution in my house
i remember when it came back on the air
because it's going back
i guess they said he's been doing the
show for like 36 years
or something like that because jeopardy
existed before i was born
then went off the air and then at a
certain point they brought i guess 36
years ago they brought it back
and i have been watching it like ever
since
i can't say i've seen every single
episode of jeopardy but i've
seen [ __ ] most of them man it's
one of my favorite go-to programs like
when we're like
we don't want to start something new we
finished up something we just
want something on in the background roll
jeopardies and watch
jeopardy man so this dude like for me
for many people in the world part of our
family and
one of the greatest canadians that ever
[ __ ] lived and stuff
um and uh by all reports a nice guy
never heard it i've been in this
business 26 years i've never heard a
shitty thing about that guy ever
nobody was ever like off your back what
a [ __ ] like people are just like oh he's
a nice guy
i mean maybe he was he was running down
so they might have said alex shebeck
what a [ __ ] you should see the [ __ ]
member on that what do you mean he's no
cocktail like no i meant what a [ __ ]
holy crap
um you know and was was also like as
much as jeopardy was a part of america
like so is alex trebek like
i remember watching that episode of uh
of the x-files
where he shows up he and jessica are
playing men in black
yeah it's like because who would believe
that alex trebek is a
member of some government uh jose
chung's
uh from outer space yes
um it's like hit and alex trebek and
also remember he showed up on cheers uh
well because
cliff like cliff was on jeopardy
yeah he he always seemed to have a good
time uh you know outside of the
sphere of insulin influence outside of
being on jeopardy whenever
he popped up in something he seemed to
be enjoying it and whatnot
um and again by all reports
wonderful dude and a dude who you know
wasn't an educator but educated people
it was very upfront about like i'm not
an educator i'm just a guy that reads
the questions but
he facilitated that knowledge you know
he made it go down smoother and like a
good teacher
never seemed to make any of the
contestants feel stupid
you know for like some obviously [ __ ]
way wrong answers and [ __ ] like that
always had the patience and the tone
well
canadian you know just very like they
picked the right guy to host that show
because i know if i was the host and
sometimes you get these answers you'd be
like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you that's the
question what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
here's the answer you got everything
wrong so the dude had the patience and
the tolerance and stuff like that and
then of course
the graciousness uh and the humility um
and the bravery the courage with which
he faced uh
his disease what did he have cancer he
had cancer yeah pancreatic cancer i
believe
um yeah did you ever try out for
jeopardy
no i did once did you really i did yeah
we're on east coast like when they were
coming through town
yeah in new brunswick i went to like a
to a hotel
ballroom in new brunswick and you know
by rutgers yeah sat in a room with you
know a couple hundred other people you
know waiting to take our test
and uh you know get in there you take
the test and you know it's all
pen and paper like you don't get the big
board and you don't get a host or
nothing but the first round is
all right let's uh we'll time you we'll
see how fast it takes you to get these
answers and
if you hit some certain mark we'll call
you back they didn't call me back
no yeah i spent i spent a day trying to
get on jeopardy
and didn't make it past the first round
you're uh rosie perez in the first half
of white man
your day is coming my day is coming yeah
it's like that's one of those shows
where you could have a
good streak of episodes where you feel
like you know some [ __ ] and then there
can be
just whole months where you get nothing
oh you ain't kidding whenever they do
the college tournaments that's what i'm
like
how do i not know any of this is this
new math new english
new history because i don't know i would
always
tune in for the celebrity uh jeopardy
which was the most remedial jeopardy you
can have
because yeah that i mean between
celebrity jeopardy
and the one he didn't host rock and roll
jeopardy which i think was like vh1 at
one point
those were like the [ __ ] i could do
this [ __ ] in my sleep jeopardies
yeah it's like i i'm i'm probably as
smart as dana carvey so sure
let's watch celebrity jeopardy um sure
man dana carver is [ __ ] smart
he's as sharp as a cookie but uh
um but yeah so so rest in peace alex
trebek rest in peace ken spears
um years old for alex trebek 82 for ken
spears man
yeah we should all be so lucky
to live that long and produce so much
joy
for others in the world indeed we'll be
missed
as we say on hollywood babylon huge
bucket of wind
for those people indeed um but that
brings us to the end
of the of the news dump it's all the
content
yeah the news done all the precincts
have reported in
and there's your news uh we're
uh cnn is uh
is ready to announce that uh we are done
with the news portion of the show
indeed now steve kornacki
and
this section of the show this is the
section of the show
um where we do q a where things you want
to know
we're going to try to answer for you uh
jc
is the facilitator of these here
proceedings jbc has the baby
come yet are you still with us baby is
not here but i'm getting text messages
from jen to uh
to come in and eat dinner i told her
we're
at q a we're almost there all right
let's do these questions fast we can
go be with this lady this is the last
time he gets to eat dinner with his lady
before he becomes a [ __ ]
family man so enjoy his dinner with his
lady
last time there were two people at that
table i do have a couple
comments from the chat uh prime march on
twitch
uh suggested levar burton to replace
alex trebek
which i
i would 100 be down with that yeah and
uh joe tracy and youtube
said that uh kevin you and the child are
the same
age right now you're both 50.
oh that's right the child is 50. and uh
they
that was the big bait and switch from
episode one right because they told you
in eight
so you were never thinking oh it's gonna
be a baby yoda and then all of a sudden
you're like
oh yeah those [ __ ] age differently
and jason
resident star wars like expert in the
house
they've never said what yoda is right
i believe yoda's species was one of the
things
that um at least pre disney was off
limits
you couldn't delve into more of
like what his species was although they
did have yaddle
in episode one sitting on the jedi
council the female
of yoda's species but you weren't
allowed to say
what he was or where he was from so wait
there was a girl yoda
in episode one in episode one yeah
sitting in the jedi council
i don't remember her named yaddle
and it's yoda with wig it's yoda with a
wig
basically yeah yoda and drag
um so what are the chances then
on the mandalorian that they're going to
show us you know because he's always
trying to get him back to his people
are we going to see a [ __ ] planet
iotas one day my guess
is that uh ahsoka shows up
and says i've been scouring the galaxy
and i
can bring him back um and at the end of
rebels i believe ahsoka and bo katan
probably they kind of became friendly so
i think that they reach ahsoka through
bogota that's my hypothesis i know
nothing
but that's my what my guess would be so
they have
yoda ahsoka i saw and what
in the show [ __ ] and we're done yeah oh
no that kid ain't going nowhere
like [ __ ] 18 man teenage group by the
time they [ __ ] let him go move on
um the uh the
iris what did i see i saw an article uh
this week that like it was speculation
but i was like
oh that's cool speculation [ __ ] it was
just on the tip of my tongue and i
forgot it
oh well you think they're gonna wait for
george to die before they tell us
who and where he's from like because
wouldn't that kill him
like wouldn't that literally just be the
last time if i'm them i'm like
and you know who did the episode where
we go to yoda planet and you find out
what a species is
and [ __ ] who he came from and all the
other yodas and [ __ ] and
george like you get him to come on write
and direct that episode then
[ __ ] canon plus it's huge everybody's
like
the master has spoken about yoda and
given us more information on yoda
i mean honestly though who
who's responsible for all we know of
yoda already
probably more lawrence kasdan than
george lucas right because didn't
lawrence kazan write empire strikes back
yeah lawrence and lee bracket um
but i mean it came up with the story and
went on and said hey man there's yoda
and he's a jedi master but
you know i wonder how much of it was
their influence as well
yeah i don't know all right we got a
good question so jake
uh the one last thing i had uh you
mentioned uh
gremlins which was don't get them wet
don't feed them after midnight the last
one was
bright light don't get him don't expose
him to this song
is that it okay that's the third gizmo
bright light bright light
hello yeah i mean the old man said that
he was like keep him away from the
lights and [ __ ]
i i don't know i'm just regurgitating
what chapman's talking about
i think you're right but because i
remember there were three things it's
like you can't get them wet
you can't feed them after midnight
and no matter what you do when the third
one like and don't ever
touch their dicks
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right what's the question okay azd
sin city magic
wants to know if you could combine two
80s movies
to make a new movie which two would you
choose and he suggested big trouble in
little china
and the golden child oh
what a good combo that is um
i mean i i'm tempted to say big trouble
in little china
and buckaroo banzai because a lot of
people thought
one was the original version of the
other they just happen to have a share a
writer
you d richter um let's see
two different movies from the 80s
all right i'm going to make the last
starfighter one of them
because okay enough of that in our lives
couldn't pull
and what would you combine with the last
starfighter
um knight of the comet ooh
nice so it's a it's a desolate barren
earth that
that uh in the kid what was his name
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i forget the main character's
name but alex
alex rogers alex that's it alex which
she's like i love you alex what's his
last name
i love you alex rogan um he comes back
to earth after
defeating is what was zorn in the
chordae armada or whatever zore and the
codename
thank you um and [ __ ]
the comet has taken almost everyone
off earth
he's looking for his girl you know
because he knows like she i believe
she's she's still alive but he's got to
[ __ ] fight those zombies and [ __ ]
like that
i don't know that that grounds it too
much the beautiful thing about last
starfighters [ __ ] was up in the
stars
and he takes a girl with it um can i
pick a movie from a different era
so can i do last starfighter plus
um galaxy quest because that would be a
mind [ __ ] right there
oh now what you could do you could do
live star fighter and flash gordon
oh two earthlings going to different
worlds having a [ __ ] deal i like it
and so alex rogan and whatever his
girlfriend's name
is like end up on [ __ ] [ __ ]
when they think i'm gonna go back and
get my girl great here's the coordinates
to come back and then suddenly it's
you know they're through the the lava
lamp skies
and suddenly it's you know war rocket
ajax is coming to escort
the uh the last starfighter ship
whatever the hell that was
oh what is the movie um
bring them through the ring of fire the
football movie with burt reynolds that
adam sandler redid
oh the longest yard so it's you mix
the longest yard and flash gordon
so you do the whole [ __ ] movie with
him getting out of jail
and then when he gets out with
scientists they get into a ship and then
you have pothole adventure
oh very nice what's your name
uh i'm gonna i'm gonna mix i'm gonna
mash up
um ferris bueller's day off nice and
weird signs
oh yeah i feel like you know ferris is
enough of a computer geek
that he could probably write the program
to create the perfect woman after sloane
breaks up with him clearly
um because you know that that one day
they spent is crazy and weird and it was
clear that he was never going to be
his uh her man and so he creates
lisa him and cameron and and they go on
crazy [ __ ] adventures and mutants
do they meet up with it's gary our boy
what the hell you're talking about i
want you to shut up
a little chips dips change whips little
kendall wax on the nipples
did they cross over with gary and wyatt
i
i think they would have to i think they
wouldn't have to oh
you know what you could do there's
there's a world in which weird science
is uh is the the hidden nested prequel
to iron man where robert downey jr's
[ __ ] character like that was him in
high school
oh my god that was the tony stark
he grew up to be tony stark and he
absolutely hired those two guys
gary and wyatt to uh to come work at
stark international
and there were the ones they're gonna be
villains in a future movie then
because everyone's always mad anybody
that ever [ __ ] worked for
worked with knew tony stark eventually
becomes a villain
i feel like there's yeah we should
absolutely make the the coherent theory
of the robert downey jr universe
and have all of this [ __ ] just work and
then have anthony michael hall show up
in
you know another iron man movie they
could use footage from johnny be good
man because we're both in that
yeah man [ __ ] i wonder why like
because they were friends back in the
day maybe they were like drug friends
and maybe that's why you don't hang out
with them or something
it'd be dope to see [ __ ] um
anthony michael hall like every movie
robert downey jr made in the 80s
can all be a prequel to tony stark like
back to school is tony stark in [ __ ]
college
is tony stark with addiction issues you
mean
dick
[Laughter]
as a [ __ ] teenager like i was a
senior when that came out
um like that was the [ __ ]
the thing that captured everyone's
imagination was like
he was sucking dick [ __ ] like
for for he was forced to suck dick
pokemon
and the guy walks in and he's like i
thought it was cool and [ __ ] like that
that's what haunted a lot of people when
we saw it back in
1988 people were like oh man yeah
so i want to i want the internet i want
somebody on the internet because i'm
never going to do it because i
don't have the skills or the the
patience to create this super cut
of 80s robert downey jr movies that all
sort of play
as the the uh the precursor to iron man
you heard him people you got an
assignment go be creative
yes go go make a thing and bring it to
me make mark what he wants
all right jc give us another question
okay next question is from
kenneth sorak um earlier in the show
whatever will be will be
the future is not ourselves
what's up buddy okay uh earlier in the
show mark mentioned mandalorian is kind
of doing the greatest hits of other
movies
like dune and aliens uh what other movie
would you mash up
with the mandalorian and the characters
oh um
i feel like we are we are probably not
that far off from a road warrior episode
of uh of the mandalorian where there is
some you know
poor town stuck in the middle of the
desert on some planet somewhere that has
the last source of uh
of fuel and there's a bunch of marauders
who are camped outside of it and
and somehow the mandalorian needs one
thing inside and
in exchange for that bit of information
he's gotta you know do some
crazy awesome wonderful dangerous
mission to get it
um and i just look forward to seeing
what uh
what famous actor gets to play the
mostly naked lord humongous
on the mandalorian yeah
it's the rock what is the exact question
um let's see
uh mandalorian's kind of doing the
greatest hiss of other movies
what other movie would you like to mash
up with the mandalorian
clerks
[Laughter]
that would be very good for me and my
brand
style of bob i would like to see them
mixed up with the mandalorian
that'd be so good for me um let me see
what other kind of
story lines would i like to see
yeah they they've done dune they've done
aliens they did
magnificent seven last season um
hidden fortress you know karasawa has
always been in the dna
so maybe some people like they did it
it's called star wars you jerk
but i'm like i get it
um hmm
courtship of eddie's father they could
do
the episode like that where you know
[ __ ]
baby yoda has to understand that [ __ ]
the mando mando's got needs
he wants to meet a new woman and so and
always be hanging out with him
and stuff like
mando's got to do what mendo's got to do
yeah
i don't know i'm not that clever that's
why they don't hire me for these things
i wonder if at some point well the the
boba fett story will get to be the
unforgiven
like you know the old gunslinger it's a
good married ned right or i'll come back
and kill all you
sons of [ __ ] yeah i mean really it
feels like they'll do every iteration
of the western story yeah
yeah they'll find a way and you know
there's plenty to choose from they've
made westerns for 50 years
and there are some fantastic ones out
there ooh do silverado i like that
that'd be great that'd be great the man
who showed up
oh my god yeah well yeah do [ __ ] uh
true grit
yes i always go backwards when i'm
backing up
um all right jc give us our third and
final question so you could go eat
dinner
all right yeah they got more shenanigans
from uh
fripp25
if you decided to do a predator tv
series
where each season is a different time
period
which time period would you want to see
or make so i guess
if you were to do an episode of this
made-up predator series
where would you set the predator and
what time period
1970s studio 54 baby
[Laughter]
there's andy warhol there's lee
radziwill
there's [ __ ] roy cohn and suddenly
in comes the [ __ ] predator
taking [ __ ] out and [ __ ] while
people are
high on cocaine and [ __ ] in the
rafters and [ __ ]
yeah that would be entertaining as [ __ ]
watch the hell out of that
over here over here over here the
cocaine's over here
over here they're like come on don't you
don't have to kill everybody do a bump
man
you've got to lower the moon we're going
to dance this far michael jackson's over
there making out with dino ross it's
totally cool
he's just killing a bunch of famous
people from the 70s
nice the 80s don't happen because
there's nobody left from the 70s
uh i i think i also choose the 70s
i choose the 70s i choose san francisco
and and i think that uh the predator
gets confused for the zodiac killer so
good
so good i saw i saw i smelt what you
were cooking the moment you did with san
francisco
and i was like that's good yeah dope
yeah man you hide
that was the jaws movie that i wanted to
do years ago is i wanted to hide
jaws uh a serial killer around jazz so
there was a guy who was like
killing people but then he'd get rid of
their bodies in the [ __ ]
drink and that attracted a [ __ ] shark
and then a storm broke out and the town
got flooded and the shark was
[ __ ] already there and stuff so there
was like a murder mystery and this thing
going on so that'd be [ __ ] dope man
story of of like the whole city thinking
that it's the
[ __ ] zodiac killer but it's really
this guy and you could have the predator
kill the zodiac killer
totally you know the cops are thinking
that clearly there's just a [ __ ]
you know serial killer out there but
there's one guy you know maybe it's the
your robert downey jr journalist who's
like guys
no it's not that i swear you're gonna
think i'm crazy
it's an alien like [ __ ] and then the
zodiac killer shows up
dead on the doorstep of the hanging from
a tree outside the police station
and people are still dying i'm just
gonna say it again this is a [ __ ]
million dollar idea
stop making those [ __ ] predator
movies you should save this idea and
give it to them that's legit wonderful
man
even if they're like we don't want to do
zodiac it's like fine just make it a
serial killer
he's hiding like the serial killer is
being mistaken for this guy or vice
versa
it's new york cinesan yeah woo
ooh someone say some of sam version of
[ __ ] predator
[Music]
um what a great answer man you're such a
good writer [ __ ]
i know i want to watch that movie that's
right that's all right
sounds more interesting to me than the
last five predator movies
like where you're like holy [ __ ] i'd
watch that man it's [ __ ] i think he's
the zodiac killer and [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] dope and it's a period piece
so like they're saying they've been here
and they've been here before that's
[ __ ] tight
yeah and you don't you then don't have
to play the weird game the predator
movies play which is
at least prior to two was didn't factor
into the audience had seen predator 1 so
i was like
what's the mystery who's killing all of
these jamaican voodoo guys
yeah i know i know
the guy in the picture on the poster
yeah i've seen him on the poster
um boy that's a great answer [ __ ] that's
quality right yeah that's an answer so
good it might force jc's kid to be born
right now yeah just spin around out to
shoot i want to watch predator 1977.
the kid's going to be like oh what
that's the kind of ideas that await me
out in this world
freak me out uh there it is
three questions and we answered them and
we gave you a bunch of news and we
talked about all the things that matter
and we [ __ ]
hung out with free baby yoda thank you
sideshow collectibles
um what a [ __ ] good time
man and just think about it when it's
all done tomorrow morning
a baby's gonna be born not because of it
but
in spite of it
we did our best to stem the tide what
happened nonetheless
we told jc like you tell jen hold on we
got a show to do
and then let nature take its course what
happened
right then have dinner and then have a
baby yeah speaking of which let's let
them get to dinner man jc come in and
say goodbye to everyone
give them a last look at you before your
life changes forever
uh unmute unmute
can't hear you buddy oh there we go
there he is uh thank you to everybody in
the chat thank you guys
i'm excited we'll reveal the baby name
next week
you'll everybody will find out if it has
anything to do with star wars
which it might kind of when did you pick
the name how long ago
uh we picked it was the first name we
came up with
back in the day when we found out and
then we decided that
we weren't gonna go with that name and
we picked like three other names
and then about a month and a half ago we
were like oh no we like that name
so we came to it it was the first name
we came up with
and then we let it go and then came back
to it
nice it's yavin isn't it
it's definitely princess leia solo
um [ __ ] a man there it is ladies and
gentlemen we gathered and we
we we gathered to talk about fat man
but we went beyond
that's what the show's called right
there we don't it's we don't bury it
it's right there in the title
somebody in the chat says that the baby
needs to be in the next view of skew
movie
so maybe there needs to be a baby
written into
the mall rats movie done and done baby's
the cheapest special effect you could
put in a movie
people love seeing little human beings
and [ __ ] we could dress up your kid
make your kid look like this make a
[ __ ] fortune did you see that
um hold on let me see i don't know how
to do this well i i guess i could do it
on my phone
it was online today um
the the picture of of
let me see if you can see that oh my
gosh
he-man delorean that's amazing
isn't that dope man it's a [ __ ] turn
baby yoda into orco
people are so clever they really are
man people are so [ __ ] talented and
[ __ ] it makes me embarrassed sometimes
that like
i got a break in this business cause
like that is more [ __ ] talented than
like clerks
get that [ __ ] career and [ __ ] or a
woman it was amazing
um but it also coincided with i've
uh now seen the fourth episode
uh of uh our masters universe show
fully animated and it looks [ __ ]
amazing and it's a very
orco heavy episode and stuff so yeah
good times i saw mark's episode
weeks ago uh fully animated and [ __ ]
good times
we would not have a show uh we're not
for the guy
sitting there there there
no there there he is yeah give it up for
mr mark bernardin ladies and gentlemen
oh thank you sir thank you very much
thank you to jc
and to andrew for giving their time now
jc and andrew are about to have a baby
together
he and jen are having a baby uh andrew
of course will
be there while they're having the baby
andrew's going to be in a side room
switching cameras
making sure the mic is hot
thank you to those good folks for
putting together a show for us to do
tonight
and whatnot and thank you good folks
either on uh youtube watching or on my
facebook page watching
uh for hanging out with us uh as talk
about
uh life the way we all like it to be
life if we all had one of these
[Laughter]
i don't know what these cost but i'll be
honest with you like [ __ ] i would pay
it
this is worth it i feel like i might
have to buy one of those for somebody
for christmas
i don't know they sent they sent two to
the house one for me and one was
addressed to my kid
and my kids in dallas shooting a tv show
so i was like
maybe she don't know if you don't know
don't hurt her maybe i got two baby
yodas and [ __ ]
i can put them on the end of my desk so
when you walk in they look like little
gargoyles
one man and two babies i don't know um
some people out there in the audience
going you
[ __ ] sick one percenter [ __ ] all
the baby yodas
you have them all don't you yoda
inequality
um hey canada
movies opens there on thursday in
toronto
if you wanted to be part of the movies
experience movies is open in a kitchen
hub uh right there in toronto uh near
downtown and then spreading out we're
gonna get to
hamilton if we're lucky as well uh go go
to movies.moviespopup.com
uh to make reservations right now whole
first week is almost completely
like sold out so thank you everyone
who's already signed up
thank you to all the folks who came out
to chicago
last week for movies pop-up that just
ended on uh saturday and that went
really well and stuff
and in 2021 we already have
six cities lined up where we're gonna be
taking movies
so we keep going man yeah it's gonna
keep going until one of us gets coveted
we're counted
[Music]
keep it on brand for movies outstanding
but
but uh thank you for that thanks you for
patronizing uh our movies thing and if
you're in toronto
enjoy folks i wish i could be up there
uh your prime minister wisely is
blocking all americans from bringing our
[ __ ] filthy germs above the border
and stuff
so when there's a uh you know a vaccine
believe me i'll be up there and stuff
but for right now
moviespopup.com if you're anywhere near
toronto and you can get in on the movies
fun we got
mooteen so it's poutine but
r poutine mootee is it vegan poutine
no it's not right
i don't know i i don't i don't think it
is we do have vegan options of course
i don't think i know you you know what
i think you're right i think there is a
vegan
mootin and a regular mootee if i
remember their menu correctly
look at that kids look at that so if
you're sitting there going
ah mooteen i'm a vegan now you could get
some of them [ __ ] vegan cheese curds
and [ __ ]
gravy made of mushrooms or some so [ __ ]
i don't [ __ ] with mushrooms so
camp out but uh go to moviespopup.com
see what you can order and make your
reservation whatnot
and i believe uh i believe
that's all we got for you i think so
yeah
that's it man that's it for fat man
beyond
i'm kevin smith and i'm mark bernardin
tune in next time
same fat time same
fat channels modcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith may the force be
with you
yes feel better camille this is the way
au revoir live long and prosper